hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest 24 legends of chess tournament
it's
another game uh from the legend of
vasily vancouver versus magnus carlsen
and this is uh the armageddon game so
after that win by vasily in game one
uh game two ended in a draw then in game
three uh vasily uh again tried uh his
bogo indian but magnus
improved on the uh line he played in
round one
uh and won game three so he equalized
the match and then game four was also a
fairly quick draw so this is now
armageddon
and for those of you those of you who
are new to modern online chess
armageddon means that white gets five
minutes on the clock
uh and the black gets four minutes on
the clock however if the game ends in a
draw then it's
black who wins the match so here uh
chucky needs needs to win the game
in order to win the match but it's
important to mention that he is the
first one to get to armageddon against
magnus carlsen
so magnus uh even if he wins will not be
getting
the full three points uh so without
further ado let's check it out and let's
see uh what uh
happens here i don't know who won the
coin toss uh or
uh or how it got that uh vasily got
white and magnus got black
but if i had to choose i'd say i'd say
magnus won the coin those and he he
chose black but it's
it's hard to say uh if any of you do
know do share in the comments so we can
share with everyone so without further
ado uh
vasily goes for d4 uh we have knight to
f6
c4 e6 and now bishop the g5 the so
called uh serevan attack
uh and the something um is using to
throw magnus off guard as he doesn't
want uh
an easy position for black to play he
wants to create some madness over the
board
so he can hope for for a win because
this is a five minutes against four
minutes without increments so if you go
into time trouble you are most likely to
lose the game so
h6 bishop to h4 and bishop to h7 now we
have e3
and b6 now magnus wants to get his
bishop on this beautiful diagonal and
now comes
bishop to e2 knight the c3 is a known
move in this position however bishop to
e2 is a new move so
already as of move 6 we have a
completely new game he wants to of
course counter uh carlson's bishop on
this long diagonal so bishop b7
we have bishop to f3 now threatening to
capture on b7 and here we have a
a trade on f3 captures captures uh
and knight to e4 now carlson wants to of
course
exchange as many pieces as possible and
uh
vasily says okay but queen to c2 first
so you capture that i'm gonna capture
the knight on e4
so magnus defends it with f5 and only
now does a chooky trade we have captures
captures
and now knight to e5 so a very active
square for the knight for both of these
knights to be
uh to be uh you know more precise uh we
have castles by magnus and
now uh here magnus allows knight the g6
this fork
uh to the queen and the rook however it
is a very complicated idea but it is the
best move for white
uh uh vasily did not play it he castled
instead but i will show it since uh this
is uh you know a video where we show
what could have happened
uh and knight to g6 uh this uh it was
not played because you have to
spend a lot of time calculating queen to
b for check knight blocks
uh and then after this rook moves now
the idea is a3 you give up this pawn to
get
this knight back into the game with an
attack on the queen so characters
and then an attack on the queen queen to
a6 and now you just win back your
opponent with captures captures and
captures with an attack on the rook
uh and uh well just a very strong
position for white
so uh this could have been played but
like i said if you start thinking you
you you get into time trouble and you
are definitely going to lose so
vasily does well he just castles without
spending too much time
and queen to e8 now magnus just wants to
control these squares here
uh we have f3 now challenging the knight
uh so the knight needs to move back we
have knight f6 and now
knight to c3 uh and here magnus kicks
back
uh the the knight from e5 so d6 and now
knight back to d3 uh we have knight beat
to d7
continuing development and now comes
rook 8
e1 so basically white has completed the
development and now needs to figure out
how to push for a win
as if you don't win you lose the match
so queen f7 by magnus
preparing to bring the the last rook
into the game and now
e4 uh with f captures on e4 f
captures an e4 uh with an excellent
center for white and
a very nice open f file for the rook so
d5 by magnus
sorry not d5 e5 by magnus and here d5
just closing the position
uh we have queen to g6 now getting the
queen out of arms away
and now that uh so the knight can move
and here comes knight to b5 and the
situation on the clock is two min two
and a half minutes for
uh vasily and some a minute and a half
for magnus but he started with a minute
less so it is to be expected
we have rook f the c8 you do need to
defend this pawn here
uh and now that this has been played
knight's the b4
uh the man who said that the strongest
move to find is a move with the knight
back uh
brings both of his knights forward with
a6 challenging this knight and now and
now comes not
the retreat of the knight but rather
knight to c6 going for this knights to
e7
hoping for a royal fork but magnus just
moves it just king to h8 so now he has
to move the knight
knight to c3 and now comes rook back to
f8 as it is no longer necessary to
defend the c8 pawn
and now b4 by choki uh we have rook to
f7
and now comes rook to f3 both players
now want to double up
on the f file which they do so rook8
rook e to f1 and now comes knight to b8
black just wants to trade off as many
pieces as possible this is one very
strong knight
so knight captures we have rook captures
at least
now you will dislodge the rook for from
the open f file at least for a bit
and queen to a4 going after this a6 pawn
but also maybe queen to c6 will
be an idea going after the c7 pawn so
here rook to a8
defending and now not queen to c6 which
could be very interesting but rather c5
an incredibly strong move uh reminiscent
of uh
uh of uh vasily's c5 move against gary
kasparov uh in their 1991 linares
clash where he just freed the c4 square
for his knight not
not any connection to this game i just
thought of it when i saw c5
and here the problem with b5 is that me
although it could be played it requires
too much calculation because you have
to see what happens after knight
captures on b5 you cannot capture
because the rook hangs
uh and you give up the e4 pawn now cd6
we have c
captures on d6 knight captures with a
nice fork here
now comes queen d4 fortune king h1 and
now rook back and now
uh white is up upon for the moment but
who
who's to say who's doing what here it's
uh i mean
it's incredible uh just to even start
calculating this especially with a game
with no
increment so here after c5 we have b
captures
on c5 by magnus b captures on c5 and now
d captures in c5 so doubling his c pawns
uh but now queen to c6 going after both
the pawns
rook to b8 now hoping to get some rook
to b2 action as the queen here could
be used uh uh to threaten checkmates
sorry my my aero game is a bit off in
this video
uh and here just rook to g3 i'm not
going for
for this capture right away first he
wants to get his uh rook
uh uh well he's king some safety he
doesn't want this queen to be attacking
it
queen to h7 a bit of a passive square
for the queen but he is
uh preparing to capture uh this
this pawn as soon as this rook either
moves uh or is defended as you don't
want to lose it
so rook to f5 and now uh
with with some idea so of capturing an
e5 so
rook beat the f8 just uh doubling up on
the f file once again so you have to be
very careful here like uh do you capture
the e5 pawn now
uh if you do then just knight captures
on e4 and the well now this is threat
and this is threat and the rook to f1
checkmate is threatened
uh not not something you want to do so
rook g back to f3
uh and now comes queen to g6 the queen
returns to a very active square
and again some ideas like rogue b8 the
b2 with a threat of mate could uh come
into into play uh and here rook captures
on e5
is definitely the way to go as now you
don't have to worry about any discovery
since there's another rook on f3 rookie
five here
uh is definitely uh a good move uh queen
captures an a6 also
queen captures on c5 on the other hand
the move uh vasily played not so much
because uh well uh because the queen is
now in range of the knight here so
knight captures an e4 is a possibility
right away but magnus goes for rook to
b8 instead he first
wants to get his his rook over to b2 uh
but now
again uh you could just uh well you
could try a lot of things
queen a7 now is a very very very nice
idea because after rook to b2
you can just push away the queen with
rook to g3 so it's not not a problem
however vasily played the only possible
move that
well not the only but one of the few
possibilities that lose the game on the
spot
he played queen to f2 and that's just
terrible
because it blunders the game on the spot
so feel free to pause the video here
and win the game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
now uh well uh the the the
the knight capture on e4 comes with both
an attack on the queen
and on the knight uh and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures on e4 and now the point
is
this is attacked this is attacked this
is attacked twice
uh and also well the most important
thing is that if knight captures an e4
then
you allow rook to be one check and there
is no square for the king now because
the queen blocked the king so this is uh
what results in in in vasily's demise
and now of course you'd have to give up
your queen with captures captures and
captures but
then you're just left with a queen
against tonight
another possibility would be for example
after knight captures on e4
uh to go for rook captures on f7 try and
go for a nice queen sacrifice
like this but still after queen d3 and
even if you
get a pair of rooks off the board check
check and king h7
uh you're still a rook and knight
against the queen and
there's just no way you can you can even
hope to
to to play this so after this knight
captures an e4 move uh vasily
immediately resigned as he saw what
happened when he played queen to f2
and magnus wins the match but uh
vasily gets one point and he's the only
person to get uh
one point against against magnus in this
entire tournament so far
uh no one was able to reach the
armageddon against magnus so
uh brilliant play by uh the legend of
vasily manchuk
uh and uh some of you have been saying
that okay maybe it's
not fair to decide matches with
armageddon but you have to decide them
somehow i mean it's
it's better than a coin toss and uh
these are still the preliminaries of the
legends of chess tournament in the
knockout
phases of the tournament there will be
four rapid games then they go into two
blitz games and only after two blitz
games will there be an armageddon but
you i mean you have to
uh you know you have to decide somehow
and i i do believe it is better than a
coin toss
so yeah uh excellent play by by both of
them magnus uh emerges victorious in the
end uh
and we are you know the end result is
that we are
all enjoying the show so uh once again i
do hope you enjoyed it
i would like to thank uh adam giffert uh
henry hawkinson
uh tom haythorne's weight uh rainer
gibbons and
mike gert for contribution contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the
legends of chess uh tournament checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday
sorry saturday